hey this is presh talwalker this meme
has confused a lot of people
me so 32 degrees F is equal to zero
degrees C right
teacher yes
me so zero degree C plus zero degree C
is equal to 64 degrees F
teacher what what
we have a genuine mathematical crisis we
start out with the correct equation but
when we seemingly add equivalent things
to both sides of the equation we end up
with a nonsensical result that zero
degrees C plus zero degree C is equal to
64 degrees F we know that can't be true
so what is going on here
let's take a step back we have two
temperature scales Centigrade and
Fahrenheit
they're described by a linear
relationship between the two
we could have the equation degree C is
equal to five over nine degrees F minus
32 or we could do the reverse which is
degrees F is equal to 9 over 5 degrees C
plus 32.
let's use the second equation
but first let's have a common example
let's say you have a smart thermostat in
your home that's set in Fahrenheit
if you set it to 68 degrees F that's
exactly equal to 20 degrees C
now you would say something like raise
the thermostat by one degree Fahrenheit
this is something we say all the time so
it seems obvious that you can add
temperature that you have 68 degrees F
plus one degree f
so what would happen here
you would end up with a thermostat
that's set to 69 degrees F
now if you convert back this is
approximately equal to 20.6 degrees
Centigrade
so the change in centigrade we go from
20 degrees centigrade to 20.6 this is an
increase of about 0.6 degrees Centigrade
so we can see what happens when we
change the temperature
now let's imagine we're working in
Celsius and for some reason we have zero
degrees Celsius here
so that is equal to 32 degrees
Fahrenheit
now what would happen if we say raise
the temperature or change the
temperature by zero degrees Centigrade
what would happen our thermostat would
still read zero and here 0 degree C is
equal to 32 degrees F
so we can notice that we've changed the
fahrenheit by nothing we've raised this
by zero degrees Fahrenheit
so we can see that if we add zero
degrees Centigrade we're adding zero
degrees Fahrenheit we're not just adding
degrees Centigrade we're going to change
the temperature so we're looking at a
change in the degrees of centigrade
so let's work this out mathematically we
know that degrees Fahrenheit is equal to
9 over 5 degrees Celsius Plus 32.
now if we apply the Delta operator or
the change to both sides of the equation
we get that a change in degrees
Fahrenheit is equal to a change of 9
over 5 degrees celsius if we solve this
for degrees Celsius we get that a change
in degrees Celsius is equal to a change
of 5 over 9 degrees Fahrenheit
so this is what we want to apply to our
original problem
so we have that zero degrees C is equal
to 32 degrees F
this is a correct equation
now we try to add 0 degrees C plus zero
degrees C and we get 32 degrees F plus
32 degrees F this is wrong you can't do
this
what you are actually doing is you're
taking 0 degree C and you're adding a
change of 0 degrees C
so then what does the equation become
a change of 0 degree C is exactly equal
to a change of 0 degrees F by this
equation
so our equation then becomes 32 degrees
F that's the conversion of 0 degree C
plus a change of 0 degrees F
now the left hand side 0 plus 0 is of
course equal to zero and on the right
hand side we have 32 plus 0 and that is
equal to 32. so we end up with a very
boring equation that zero degrees C is
equal to 32 degrees F
so now let's bring It full circle
me so 32 degrees F is equal to zero
degrees C right
teacher yeah
me so zero degrees C plus zero degrees C
is equal to 64 degrees F
teacher obviously not adding a change of
0 degrees C is equivalent to adding a
change of zero degrees F
so zero degrees C plus a change of 0
degrees C is equal to 32 degrees F plus
a change of 0 degrees F and that means
zero degrees C is equal to 32 degrees F
you can't outsmart me
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]